seen is the worst outcome even when
other things are accounted for for
people from more deprived populations
and I think that also ties into some of
the work that's going on around the
experience of some of our black
population in terms of healthcare
outcomes which seems to be that there is
something that you know that there is
something systematic that is
disadvantaging some groups of people
um so I think this the the impact of
deprivation is clearly having an impact
on both people's willingness to seek
help but in some cases also the offer of
help that those people receive and I
think that's something we will be
definitely wanting to return to
um thank you and and the second question
follows on I think quite quite nicely
from that which is around the the
differences in in treatment so this was
the other thing that really surprised me
um which is on page 23 and I know it's
only one study but but people in
deprivation were
um 20 less likely to receive treatment
uh essentially which you know really
shocked me
um and I know the report says you know
we don't fully understand the reasons
for that
is there any other research going on
that you know about which might look
into why that could be happening I think
there will be I mean this is obviously a
national study this is I couldn't say
that this has happened in Trafford
um and it's one study but this is the
sort of thing that again by engaging our
cancer registry and talking with them
about it that's the sort of information
that the cancer registry because because
in the in in England we have all cancer
cases recorded through the cancer
registry that gives us a very good
database under which we can then you
know with a lot of data detail in that
we can analyze the it runs at a lag so
when we ask for the um data in 2019 the
most recent data we could get was 2017
data because they spend so much time
doing that quality checking and and
quality uh you know the quality side of
the data making sure that it's accurate
before they even start analyzing it but
um we are we would this is something
that will definitely be be asking the
cancer registry about again
thanks for acting
there we go
oh no it's working now
I didn't press it hard enough
um my sort of questions is around
um you know the breakdown of alcohol use
by age and the highest age group is
um 14 to 16.
um and and obviously it's quite
concerning that and I just wonder
what what are we doing to try to bring
that down
um particularly in schools I would have
thought would be an ideal start
um but yeah I'd just be interested in
your comments so I think what we've seen
through the pandemic is the people who
were drinking quite a bit beforehand
have drunk more but quite a number of
people are now not drinking anything so
we have quite a divide now in in society
between and a lot of younger people
drink don't drink at all don't don't use
alcohol at all but those that do the
relative price of alcohol has come down
a lot
um so it is and the access of alcohol
there's much easier access to alcohol so
it is something that is is a problem
across Society but what we're seeing
with alcohol use is that there's much
less of that deprivation divide and
we're seeing much more you know the the
use of alcohol or overuse of alcohol
over consumption of alcohol is something
that's seen across much more across the
borough across all social classes I was
also talking to a colleague today about
um some of the work that the midwives do
because of course the midwives all ask
all pregnant women about alcohol use and
all pregnant women deny vehemently
drinking anything they say they very
very rarely um at any disclosure of
alcohol use among pregnant women
although the same women are quite happy
to disclose cannabis use so it it's it's
interesting how alcohol is perceived and
what's happening with alcohol but I
think we still have
um
well with smoking there is a very Stark
link between deprivation and smoking
with the more lower income groups being
very very much more likely to smoke
that's not the case with alcohol and
particularly in middle-aged populations
alcohol use is very much the norm and
people can quite often start drinking a
little bit more and a little bit more
without really realizing what's
happening so it is something that I
think is a message for all of us across
society that we have absolutely
normalized we've denormalized smoking in
most communities but we haven't
denormalized over consumption of alcohol
okay
um I think that's only committee
um questions uh can I just um draw
attention to the the
um the latter part of the report the um
the page 26 the half page there and the
interesting
um point that you make that you're
potentially secured 30 000 pounds
funding
um
for
um early diagnosis of lung cancer
I'm just wondering if there's if there's
anything that you can add to that
anytime
of course and also whether
um on the first bullet point that the
project will involve
it mentions an age age range of 55 to 74
and I wondered what the scope is to pull
that age range to into a younger field
still going through to 74 but involving
younger patients as well so the reason
that the so we don't know yes if we've
got the funding and we're still waiting
for to hear about that the reason that
that age range will have been chosen
will be to do with the um
relative likelihood of finding enough
lung cancers to make the program
worthwhile and we have the same with
breast cancer Services as well that it
starts at a particular age because
that's the point at which you're likely
to find enough cases to make it work
asymptomatic cases to make it worthwhile
obviously this is a this is um for
people who don't have symptoms this is
early diagnosis so if anyone had a
persistent cough or other signs of lung
cancer whatever age they were we would
be you know we would strongly be
encouraging them to go to the GP this
this program is is targeted at a very
specific age group because that's the
age group where we think we will find
enough to make it worthwhile and that
their outcome is it will you know that
you can actually change the outcome for
that population so that would be the
reason for that age group and it it will
have been it's it's nationally set
and you mentioned that the the funding
isn't uh secured yet is there anything
that we can do to help get that secured
I will try and find out and if there is
I will definitely be in touch with you
and uh
Diana put you on the spot with a what
maybe thought of as a slightly
ridiculous question but I think in in
your directorate the
um budget money monitoring year to date
is it's looking
pretty good
I wondered whether there would be a
little bit of
um
money that could be fired into this sort
of work in Partington
um it is the older end of the age range
that we're looking at and just uh I'm
just wondering the importance of this
work whether there's uh even a little
bit that could be found to to help
um in in that area
thank you for that
um it's a really important piece of work
and we're very committed supporting
residents in Partington as we are in all
areas but with the evidence it's very
compelling we'll take it away we'll have
a look
um both Elena's budgets in public health
and any other budgets that we can source
for what we can do we'll come back with
some ideas thank you
and I'll just sort of clarify my
intentions I'm not here trying to steer
this Council I'm just trying to stir up
some ideas and if um if it brings
something out that does make a
difference then or well and good
um
and just one other point that did come
out earlier on in in the meeting you
mentioned
um
um about the the breast screening delays
um
uh is there anything that
um
that we can do to
try and move things along on on that I I
think the main thing that would be
really helpful is encouraging women to
attend when they are called the the van
moves around and has its round length
and it's difficult to get the van
outside those times because everybody in
a city in a practice will be called in
in a you're called every three years
between so the first one will be between
when you're 50 and 52 and the next so
that they they have a program of moving
around and calling all the people in a
particular area so that's why it would
be 2024 they don't go to every area
every year because we don't get called
when we're 50 and then 53 and 56 some of
us will be 51 some of us will be 52 and
so so that's why that's why the ban is
going there in 2024 there have been
problems with the round length not just
being three years but drifting upwards a
little bit so we are keeping to put that
pressure on NHS England to get that
round length back to you know to make
sure that's every in within the three
years but we wouldn't be asking for it
to go additionally within that time
because that would throw everything else
out does that make sense it's quite
complicated
um
yes just because of the way that people
are called it's not like cervical
screening where you get once you've
started you get called every three years
or every five years with breast
screening you're in a you're in a round
and you stay in that round and then you
know the next round follows it follows
it
it's because the breast skin the other
thing with the breast screening van is
it is absolutely massive and although
they call it mobile it's not actually
that mobile you have to find quite it's
quite difficult to find sites to put it
having um having worked on this when I
was working in North Manchester it
actually is very difficult
it's a fine thing places to put the van
um so but we we are really what we do do
and we absolutely insist on with um NHS
England and the screening program is we
absolutely want them to make sure they
go to where the women with the lowest
uptake are not
go to the places you know run more
sessions in the higher uptake places we
push very hard for that Equity to make
sure that it's easy for women who are
less likely to go to be able to get
there
and you mentioned about getting women to
turn up
um so we could do with some
um asking Communications to do a piece
of work on on that perhaps absolutely
yes and we will do that
sure hmm
thank you so much for the support and
um without oversimplifying it does seem
that deprivation is at the root of most
of the challenges that are
um in front of us here
do you think
um
there are any that may be more
non-medical Community
orientated sort of I hesitate to use the
word interventions because I don't want
to sound that I'm suggesting people have
something done to them because that's
absolutely wrong but
um
approaches shall we say that my
um obviously can't sort of eliminate all
the problems to do with deprivation but
just encourage people maybe to both
consider their own health and also maybe
feel a little bit more confident in
seeking help with that seems to be quite
a big issue doesn't it really that
people are quite frightened sometimes
are thinking in seeking help you know
and the fear the worst
um I I would say there's a lot that can
be done both in terms of increasing
employment opportunities and good
employment
um giving people the confidence if
you've got that confidence in your daily
life if you're in good employment you're
not working over long hours you're not
having to work three or four hours jobs
to keep keep the wolf from the door if
you're able to
um have you know the better the
education that people get in school the
more all of those are protective factors
transport Leisure Services but but you
know that you you we really can't
underestimate the impact of good
education and good quality of employment
in in giving people the skills to both
take care of their own health and and
have and and be able to negotiate that
effectively I think living in poverty is
pernicious and the longer people are in
poverty the worse those impacts are so
anything that we can do to reduce the
impact of poverty we also know in
Partington that we've got not you know
some poor mental health outcomes again
very much linked to to the challenges of
living in in difficult circumstances so
the more we can do to generally improve
people's quality of life
the more we will start to see these
these indicators change
thanks very much I mean clearly it's a
subject that um a lot of people can
relate to and
um I'm hoping that through it being an
agenda item for us tonight that we've um
maybe got some some additional thinking
going on there so thank you very much
for bringing that to us
foreign
so we've moved to agenda item six
alcohol and substance
misuse
um
and we've got to Twin team have we
before us
thank you chair uh Jilla Burgess Island
consultant in public health good evening
uh everyone
um so um this evening's report on
alcohol provides you with an update on
the previous uh scrutiny report on this
topic which came in November of 2021 and
um just by way of context we know that
alcohol is the biggest risk factor for
Deaf ill health and disability amongst
15 to 49 year olds in the UK so really
significant determinant of the health of
our communities and what we've seen
during the covid pandemic is a widening
inequalities around alcohol harm and
alcohol consumption whereby those people
who uh were already drinking at safer
levels maintain safe levels of drinking
on the whole and it was those uh cohorts
within the population who were already
drinking at harmful levels where the
increase in alcohol consumption was the
greatest
we nationally have seen an increase in
alcohol-specific
mortality during the course of of the
pandemic which is of great concern and I
hope that this evening's paper will
offer you some information and
reassurance around what we have done to
address that increasing risk locally so
you can see there are some local
statistics there we've got a spine chart
there that shows most of those
alcohol-related indicators on an
improving trajectory locally although
you'll notice towards the bottom there
there are some indicators that have
remained stable and one in in particular
where we have we have outcomes that are
significantly worse than the national
average and that is for Hospital
admissions for young people in Trafford
and that has been
um one of the indicators that has been
worse than average in Trafford for some
time and we work closely with early
break to address that they are our
alcohol treatment service for young
people you've got a trend uh graph there
for Hospital admissions for
alcohol-related conditions and Trafford
is the
um the blue line at the bottom and we
can see that there's been an improvement
over recent years and indeed we have a
lower rate of admissions than than
England on that indicator which is
encouraging to see in terms of the
Strategic context the national drugs
stretch strategy that came out in 2021
although it had a focus very much on
drugs a lot of the improvements to
services and to partnership working that
are resulting from that strategy and the
new money will also improve the
landscape for the way that we can
support people who are drinking at
harmful levels as well and more locally
we have our Trafford health and
wellbeing strategy
and that that
um
has identified alcohol harm as one of
its top five priorities and in response
to that as part of a series of Deep dive
exercises that we've been undertaking
with the health and well-being board and
we've looked in some detail at alcohol
and generated a number of actions and
recommendations and we're still in the
process of getting those approved
through the health and well-being board
and a summary of those actions will go
to the board on the 7th of February next
month
so I mentioned early break they are one
of the service providers Under the
Umbrella service achieve and we have
Jonathan here with us this evening from
achieve Trafford
um and you've got there um some detail
of
um the elements of treatment and
Outreach Services and Recovery Services
I won't go into those in any detail
um but I'm sure that Jonathan will be
able to answer any questions you may
have around any of those and in addition
we have primary care support around
drinking and looking at the performance
data you've got some Primary Care data
there in terms of brief interventions
and also some of the treatment
performance data so for example for
alcohol service users you can see that
there has been an increase in the number
of referrals for alcohol in Trafford
um very much reflecting what we've
observed nationally around consumption
trade through the pandemic
in terms of young people's referrals has
not been as much of an increase around
alcohol but what is notable is that the
majority of those referrals come from
hospital and I think that is a
reflection of that hospital indicator
that I mentioned earlier for our for our
young people
so in conclusion there has been this
acceleration in alcohol related
mortality nationally
we don't currently have a national
alcohol strategy I say that it's 2012 so
it's very old strategy but it is of note
that the government have been debating
that strategy today in Parliament so it
may be that we'll see some movement
around that agenda nationally certainly
at a GM level we're in the process of
putting the combating drugs partnership
in place and to reflect that at a local
level we are setting up a new subgroup
of the safer Trafford partnership which
will have a focus on substance misuse
and will enable us to work more
effectively with colleagues across the
system to address alcohol harm in
Trafford thank you
thank you any
canola
hi thanks Jilla thanks for the report
just a really quick question the
um the under-21s who were hospitalized
is there any information on there are
they coming from areas of high
deprivation or is it more affluent areas
because I know with
um
it varies
for that particular indicator we're not
able to drill down by geography however
what we do know from early break the
service provider for young people is
that they get a higher number of
referrals from certain Wards in the
borough and uh correct me if I'm wrong
Amy but I think it's sales retford and
ermston
and in terms of the how Hospital
admissions I don't have that breakdown
by geography
I could probably just add a little bit
into it my name's Emma hodgkinson I'm
the commission and support officer in
the public health Team and before I came
into this role I actually used to work
in young people's
um substance machine services and and
did see the kind of any referrals
um and I guess it's just to it's not
necessarily a link to deprivation it can
it's all different areas although
substance issues is often linked to
deprivation I think with alcohol with
young people a lot of the
incidences where there were crisis it
might be they've started drinking before
and they don't know the limits and
there's just some incidences there so
it's not necessarily
the deprivation and it's all over the
borough so just to appreciate it's
there's a lot of complex factors that
come into it in the presenter a a
H okay
um I'm not seeing any other committee
members can I just ask a question then
the
picture painted we're looking at
traffordam
um
we're drawing comparisons across the
English
average I think
um in in terms of
um countries and alcohol issues in
different countries uh
are we abnormal
are we typical
um and is there any particular messages
that maybe we could be could be drawing
I think that's a really interesting
question and
um from what I recall looking at the
international data there is a sort of
north-south divide across Europe in
terms of alcohol consumption and along
with other North European countries we
do have comparatively higher rates of
alcohol consumption in the UK I know for
example that prenatal alcohol
consumption in the UK is one of the
highest globally so I think that
comparatively we
um we have as Eleanor said earlier
normalized a level of alcohol
consumption in the UK that is damaging
to our health and I think that that
wider societal picture makes it that
much more difficult for us to really
engage with that prevention agenda I
think it's important that we work with
schools and other settings
um where we can perhaps shift some of
those social norms and it is encouraging
to see the alcohol consumption Trends
amongst our young people in the UK have
declined in recent years and there does
appear to be a shift
um in in attitudes towards alcohol
amongst young people and and we
obviously hope to see that continue
through into that cohort's adulthood
and if you wouldn't mind just clarifying
that a general point for me in the in
terms of the statistics are we talking
about people who have become ill through
their alcohol consumption or are we
including people who have become injured
through their alcohol consumption
or is it both
so um
I suppose when I was talking about
alcohol harm and harmful levels of
drinking that's not necessarily
reflected in the hospital figures and
when we look at those Hospital
indicators there are different
indicators there are alcohol specific
and alcohol related those that are
alcohol specific are admissions or or
deaths where the main factor
contributing to that admission or death
is alcohol and there's a much broad
broader
group The alcohol-related conditions and
and mortality which includes
where alcohol is a secondary Factor so
there are different ways of defining it
but what we do know is that drinking at
harmful levels impacts on a whole range
of cancers and other physical conditions
and indeed has a knock-on effect on
mental health and on community safety
and why to social things
councilor Brophy
thank you for the report I'm just a
curious about
knowing a bit more about the red figure
that is in Trafford the admission
episodes of alcohol specific conditions
for under 18s on page
29 I think that is and there's a bit at
the back
um on young people under 21.
and then there's some breakdown of the
ages I'm just wondering about the fact
that it's higher in traffic can I ask if
you know how the young people are
getting the alcohol are they having
alcohol at home
and they're just kind of having policies
at home
are they buying it are they getting
older children to buy it I know there's
examples just from being a ward
councilor where
sometimes
um teenagers will get older teenagers to
buy the alcohol for them and then it's a
kind of trading issue isn't it any I
think there was a an example of um
people who kind of go in to see whether
the stores will sell alcohol to a young
person or not so I'm just wondering are
young people going into pubs I'm just
wondering where where is the alcohol
coming from that leads to
such a high instance for
people under 18. it would usually be a
combination really
um and it's something that elevate will
look into when they have when they come
out of the hospital and they have that
assessment that's something that would
explore and if they are buying it from
the um shops I know the workers what
kind of
um explore that a little bit further and
then it gets kind of reported back to
licensing teams and things like that to
look at in more depth
well thank you
um very much for
um bringing that to to us today
um
if you were interesting aspects of it
covered and but I suspect it will be an
area that we'll be covering again and
probably again
uh
but so she's a such his life
thank you very much
so the next
item item seven
is the Trafford locality Urgent Care
needs assessment and critical appraisal
scrutiny
okay
so Gareth were you wanting to introduce
it or no
okay so
um uh I'm here so still out on a roof
still director of Public Health and my
colleague at kathya Driscoll associate
director of delivery and transformation
for Trafford locality
um
back in um September I'm sure you can
all um recall we were asked to come back
in January with the Urgent Care review
um so we're at stage one of the Urgent
Care review for Trafford and so what
we're presenting today and I'm sure
you've an apologies for the the length
of the paper but we wanted to show you
that the amount of detail that's been
gone into to really try to understand
the real analysis of what Urgent Care
looks and feels like so we're at the
first stage of the Urgent Care review
which is the needs assessment so the
papers that you've seen and read through
in detail are the outputs of that Urgent
Care needs assessment so that needs
assessment is looking at what is
currently available in Trafford from an
access to urgent care that includes
everything from we're not just talking
about access to a e this includes
dentists pharmacists optometrists GPS
all the access points you can imagine
for the access of urgent cares we just
wanted to make that really clear and
Eleanor and I will what we've tried to
do in the uh presentation that was
attached is go through what some of the
key outputs so the key findings of the
needs assessments of establishing what
Urgent Care looks like in traffic
currently Eleanor will talk through the
majority of those and obviously then
we'll take questions if that would be
okay thank you
thank you so when we um in looking at
the needs for Urgent Care in Trafford
it's just worth reminding people that
most Urgent Care is actually delivered
in neighborhoods by GPS and a
pharmacists optometrists and dentists as
Kathy has said most of it's delivered
between 8 A.M and 8 p.m and the need for
Urgent Care is affected by a number of
factors and that includes the quality
and accessibility of planned and
preventative care because in many cases
Urgent Care needs can be diverted by
having good planned and preventative
care so it is quite important when we're
thinking about urgent care and Urgent
Care Services two things one is
sometimes people do have to travel
particularly out of hours to an urgent
care center but that is that is the
minority of it most of it is although
there are a lot of people using my
urgent care centers most Urgent Care is
delivered in the neighborhood by your
own GP practice or or a pharmacy and
um and that quality and accessibility of
prime of preventative Services is really
important because if we get things like
false prevention right we'll have fewer
people falling and breaking their hips
and less need for that level of urgent
care for example so
um
the
the rates of urgent care usage are
higher in the very young and the Very
Old the reason that that's higher in the
very young is that the protocols for
treatment mean that because illness can
happened so quickly in very young
children and can be you know little ones
can get very ill very quickly so it's
really important that under fives are
seen by somebody rather than by by being
offered treatment by phone or online so
that's why we have high rates in very
young children and that's why out of
ours in particular some yet very young
children might have to travel or
sometimes you know they can't get home
visits as well
the reason that the rates are higher in
the older population in in that
typically starts in the south of the
borough that that increase starts around
80. in the north of the borough that
increase starts around 70. the reason we
see
um higher rates in older people is often
older people will have comorbidities and
things that would a younger person might
shake off or it'll go back to that falls
example somebody who's 30 Who falls is
unlikely to come to any significant harm
but somebody who's 80 who's false could
well break their hip because they may
have osteoporosis or other conditions
so that's that's why we see those higher
rates in those those two in the extremes
of age uh the reason that we see the the
other reason that we the other reason
for higher rates is deprivation and
again when you look at that that
increase in the attendances going up in
the north at 70 rather than 80 that is
linked to the poorer health of our
population in the north which we've
rehearsed quite extensively with the
Partington conversation and a lot of
what we were talking about in Partington
also relates to the north of the borough
as you know
um
we've seen we saw rates of urgent care
usage drop
um during the pandemic but it's now
increasing again
um and the other big change that we've
seen since the pandemic is that we're
seeing an awful lot more same-day
appointments in general practice and a
lot more attendances at general practice
whether online or face to face and in
October this last year we've just had I
think um GPS saw a hundred thousand
people in that month compared to I think
it was 40 000 in the equivalent period
the previous year so you know the
stories that you hear about the pressure
that general practice is under we are
absolutely seeing that in Trafford and I
think you know we do need to give a big
thank you to our GPS
um who who have not always got a good
press recently but we can certainly say
in Trafford with they are working
extremely hard and have had an enormous
increase in their workloads
um overall having done the Urgent Care
review and you will have read the whole
lot it is very long it's been a big
piece of work for us to do but very
interesting overall the conclusion is
that Trafford residents have good access
to urgent care centers and that's both
because we have good public transport in
the borough and because we have high
rates of car ownership
and the main area of concern for us is
Partington because it's been identified
as an area that's at higher risk of
Transport related social exclusion
um
and it's got higher levels of need
because of the deprivation that we
discussed previously you also may be
aware that in September this year last
year we carried out a pharmaceutical
needs assessment for the borough and in
the pharmaceutical needs assessment it
was established that all areas of
Trafford have good access to pharmacies
our residents across the borough have
good access to Pharmacies with the
exception of a gap in Partington on a
Saturday afternoon and a Sunday which
we're working with NHS England to to um
to address to make sure that that Gap is
that is filled but that isn't
unfortunately the responsibility of our
local services so we are having to
negotiate to get that that improved
foreign
councilor Lloyd
well um I don't think you should
apologize for the length of the reports
I think one of the things is that these
reports that have been presented tonight
we've got much more detail therefore we
um I think a better informed
um about it as well and I thought this
was a particularly interesting report
and
um yeah Saturday afternoon and Sunday
you know
if you're
somebody like me your kids always get a
lot of older ones perhaps or somebody
always gets sales on the Saturday
afternoon and so I would hope that that
would be remedied in Partington
pharmacies I don't think people use
pharmacies as much as say
um could do and I think a lot of work
needs to be done about that because
actually they
um to me sometimes they are the first
part of calls because one they're open
they're accessible and the pharmacist
can do a lot I believe that there is
some discussion at the moment about
pharmacists being able to prescribe
antibiotics
um and and that's been looked at I mean
can they be given
more Powers if you like because
to be quite honest I know the pharmacist
knows more more about drugs than the
Doctor Who's prescribing them for me
um and
um I always tell people if you've got a
problem with ear drops go and see if
pharmacists as soon as possible
um so I just think that that service
could do I think a lot more within the
community
[Music]
and thank you yeah I would completely
concur with that as well so what were
sorry what I forgot to mention is just
running along concurrently with what
we're doing in regards to the the
obviously the vast detail that we've
gone into in regards to location sites
accessibility population variants Etc
we're also doing a quite extensive
Urgent Care
um patient engagement process so what
we've got surveys online we're going out
to and particularly to those hard to
reach Community groups to really get
what Urgent Care looks and feels like so
asking those exact questions do you
understand what your role of your
pharmacist is do you know about access
to your GP all the other places in which
you can gather information or access to
healthcare services and Urgent
Healthcare Services will also will then
use that information and that we've
gained back to form the overall piece in
regards to what that needs assessment
looks like and then have very targeted
campaigns throughout the localities
throughout the neighborhood about to
really address those
um any questions or lack of
understanding that people may have about
how to access services and where those
services are located and nationally they
are looking at the role of Pharmacists
and what pharmacists can deliver because
you're absolutely right it's a non not
untapped Market but lots of people go to
different locations for access to
services and I think the more we can
ensure that people are clear where to go
and what the role of the pharmacist is
there's a lot more work being
undertaking about what the expansion of
the role of a pharmacist that will
always be nationally LED and led by NHS
England and but we can we're obviously
through all of our localities are
feeding into that work to make sure it's
really clear what the expansion of that
role could look and feel like and what
additional resource that could really
give thank you
yeah I just want to Echo um councilor
Lloyd's um thanks for a really excellent
report really in depth that was quite
astounded I was looking back thinking
didn't we just ask for this in December
and it's been delivered now so brilliant
thank you um so just a couple of
questions that I've got um and I'm I'm
sure everybody else has probably got the
same one as me which is about
um page 46 where you mentioned altering
a minor injuries unit and how it kind of
sits outside the national guidance at
the moment and I just wondered if you
could expand on that please yeah of
course
um I was waiting for somebody to ask the
question
um so
um I'm sure it's on page 46 and it's
also in the summary presentation as well
so what we mean by sitting outside and
the national guidance is that the
national guidance dictates at the moment
um that you should not have a standalone
minor injuries unit in place and I'll
just refer to the actual word in bear
with me and anything more technical
James James Gray is has all the detail
that sits behind it but in regards to
the National framework what it's saying
thing is that minor injuries unions
should not be Standalone facilities so
the national requirements are that they
are not Standalone if you do have one in
existence then um what we should be
looking at is either the um development
of that minor injuries unit into an
urgency into an urgent treatment center
or the development of that minor
introduced it into a GP Hub or looking
at whether they there is a requirement
in place for that Standalone minor
injuries unit to be available and in
place so what in summary what they're
saying is National guidances minor
injuries need to be reviewed because
they shouldn't be
um delivering just minor injuries
facilities it should be an expansion of
or reviewing whether that service is
needed within that within the place and
within the locality
great and so what what are the next
steps for for us then when looking at
altering them obviously it's not open at
the moment and that's another point of
contention yeah and I guess I'd just
like to understand a bit more about what
an urgent treatment center is kind of
how that definition works
thank you
guys do you want to do the first point
actually works hello I'm I'm James Gray
I'm the head on scheduled care and the
Urgent Care lead for NHS greater
Manchester in Trafford so I work with
Gareth and Kathy so the report you're
looking at um I pulled that together
with obviously Ellen's team from a
public health perspective so um I'm
quite familiar with a lot of the
information in there
um from an urgent treatment center
perspective it is a primary care LED
facility uh generally open for 12 hours
a day majority of them will be 8 A.M in
the morning till 8 pm at night so if you
take Trafford General as a prime example
the majority of utcs will deal with
injuries and illnesses and the sort of
um
I'd say the middle ground of patience
really between
um primary care and Ed and so the
patients that were traditionally gone to
your walk-in centers your minor injuries
units
um sort of um any anything that's
primary care that may need um
Diagnostics or some additional Bloods
doing or um x-rays that sort of thing so
um traffic General is probably the best
example of one that I can think of at
the moment the thing that's unique about
traffic General is it's a collaboration
between two different providers so we've
got mft
um doing the um or the illness side of
things and the injuries and then we've
got a master call HealthCARE who also do
more of the primary care elements there
as well
um but it is a um I think going back to
Kathy's Point earlier and also you know
looking at what you're saying about the
pharmacy element
the way we need to approach Health at
the moment is very different we're going
through a bit of a cultural change and
what we need to work toward is actually
how patients approach the way they deal
with health so Pharmacy is an example
actually before pharmacies what we
should be saying to patients is have a
look in your own cabin at home what have
you got have you got paracetamol and
that sort of thing so
what we need to do is educate patients
in terms of how to self-care to start
off with and then pharmacies GPS
urgent treatment centers 111 Ed as a
last protocol
um there is a lot of comms guidance that
will be coming out from NHS greater
Manchester for patients around how to
approach
um their own Management in terms of
where they go for care and but yeah that
that's essentially in a nutshell what
urgent treatment centers um provide they
are um part of the Pyramid of urgent
care so foreign
thank you and obviously if we go down
that road I'm sure there'll be much more
debate um about that
um and I just had one uh other question
it's more of a request on page 66
there's a fantastic graph that showed
pie chart that shows the reasons for
attending just wondered if somebody
could pop some labels on because I
couldn't I couldn't tell the shades of
blue
um apart so yeah that would be great to
just see that separately thank you
thank you
in case of the Lloyd
and when was the guidance when did the
guidance come in about
um Standalone minor injury units
um because I'm just thinking of that
building in alteringham
um
one it's not being used now and I think
in the report it does say that you've
got somebody in wythenshaw who would do
the man injuries
um there and presumably
if you've got a minor increase unit
there will be times when you would have
to go to an urgent care you would have
to have further treatment anyway it's a
bit like the Midwifery ones in in some
respects to me but it's the first
question I particularly one um answered
and just just a minute
just in relation to
um clarification on the minor injuries
unit we're not talking about Ultraman
hospitals ultimate Hospital in its
totality the hospital remains as is
fully functioning exactly
all services living in exactly the same
way the only thing we're making
reference to that is not within National
requirements is the minor Standalone
minor interest unit element so I just
wanted to clarify that the only thing
we're talking about in relation to the
remained
um suspension of those Services is
purely about manner interests James you
want to answer what about yeah thank you
so the initial guidance around
urgent treatment center
um standards and National guidance there
was a range of standards in terms of
what you needed to achieve to be able to
be designated as an Odeon Treatment
Center that guidance was first published
in 2017. there was a deadline of
December 2019 where all localities had
to adhere to that I.E if it wasn't an
urgent treatment center it either had to
be downgraded upgraded or changed
significantly we obviously missed that
from a traffic perspective and for a
range of reasons and obviously then the
uh the covid pandemic hit and
um priorities of the system changed
significantly
um what we are seeing now from an NHS
England perspective is those actual
priorities are coming back into play so
actually we're being asked around what's
happening with the minor injuries unit
itself
um from NHS England which is obviously
um where the pressure is coming from
from our perspective it just so
coincides that actually there was a
staffing issue there at the time from an
altering a minor injuries point of view
and actually and it was the service was
suspended there anyway just from a
staffing point of view and those staff
have been redeployed to Women's Hospital
what we've seen for and you'll see this
in the report what we've seen from a
activity level perspective is those
patients who previously would have been
going towards them entries unit are now
going to windshield but as you say the
services that women sure you know if you
go to altering them and you need your
arm pinning or you need something some
surgery from a from an injuries point of
view that can't be done at altering them
you would have to go to some women show
anyway and so there are um there are
pros and cons to it but as um as Kathy
alluded to this isn't about Ultron as I
say it's about the minor injuries within
this report I think what we need to take
into account is altering the minor
injuries accounts from a very small
proportion of the patients we're talking
about
um within this within this document
um and the other thing that you
mentioned is about education for people
and and this is something that I'd said
previously in he had scrutiny I know
where to go and and to each one I
personally would know where to go
including the Specialties as well but I
know
um somebody had an accident the other
day turned up a term traffic Journal
well it was closed at eight o'clock so I
think there is
um an element of education and I don't
know how you do that education
um because people
no you know this is it they should know
that it's only eight to eight because I
thought everybody knew but obviously
they don't so it's like education that's
really important so people are not
turning up at the wrong place and then
having to travel further
um to be able to get seen as well and
actually traffic generals haven't having
said that I mean I have used that
service before or certainly my family
health and um it is very good
um so it it seems to be working really
well
um unless I hear otherwise but
and just if you wouldn't mind just to
respond to that so um one of the key
things about the review that we've done
one of the main reasons as well that's
been undertaking is the review was
always identified within the Trafford
locality plan so we were really aware
there was there's so many front doors in
traffic and access points what we wanted
to do is do that review to really see
whether all of those access points won
met the national guidance was delivering
what it needed to do to serve the needs
of the population and as part of that
review that's one of the key messages
that I'm sure we've had some feedback
already but will be coming out about the
people not really understanding what um
those different access points are and
also the change in the National guidance
was also to support people really that
everybody throughout the UK really
understanding what where they should be
going for the different types of
treatment so The Branding of the Urgent
Treatment Centers most people probably
still don't know what that is if we're
honest and that's one of the things I'm
sure we'll pick up as part of that comms
piece but
um the The Branding emergent treatment
centers meant you had that those
multi-disciplinary teams co-located in
one place so it was really clear for for
people if you had a minor injury minor
illness
um a query you knew exactly where to go
to and also with the expansion and I'm
sure you've seen some of the national
campaigns at the moment about 111 and
999 really trying to keep educate people
out where to go but for which types of
conditions as well so we'll expand that
but I think when we get that real local
in children's for Trafford we can then
really focus it can't with James in
relation to how we communicate most
effectively with the the Trafford
population to make sure that they're
really clear
I think just to add to that in terms of
the comms element I think what you've
touched upon is it's probably a cultural
aspect to it because you know people
have used traffic General in the past
for various things it may be their
parents have used it for certain things
that they've told them to go there for
you know X Y and Z so healthwatch as an
example did a report last year didn't
you have a
um around Trafford General 25 of them
still thought there was maternity
services at the hospital site
because they were probably born there
and that's and that's the bit we need to
work around a lot of this is around
educating the population about what the
system looks like what's out there and
what's available and to be fair
Urgent Care has changed drastically
since the pandemic I mean in in the last
two three years
um you know the amount of services that
we've now got available fast compared to
before
um so I think for us it's just about
making sure that we are sharing that
message
um with the public with residents in
traffic around what is available where
they can go
um and you know as the as Eleanor
touches on in in the elements around the
report traffic patients have a lot of
choices sometimes they may have too much
yeah
yeah
um I think one thing I would always
touch upon and
um is around one one
you know one one is there to direct
people where to go that's most
appropriate for their needs
um you know there's been some challenges
we've been one-on-one recently we're
aware of that we are trying to address
it but actually if you're unsure about
where to go that's the best place to go
through either online or on the
telephone
thank you
Council Leicester
is this working yeah
um back is back in September I actually
asked about why alteringum was just a
minor injuries units and not a wider
Urgent Care Center recovering sort of
health conditions as well as uh trauma
and so but
one of the one question that I would ask
is because it was only a minor injuries
unit that would have always limited who
could have actually attended there so
when we're actually looking in the
review and in terms of numbers that
doesn't it might not reflect the demand
for the services in the south of the
borough and we've spent quite a lot of
time talking tonight about Partington
and the fact that there's deprivation
and that the people don't access
Services
um yeah that probably from a locality
point of view is actually the the
closest to that area as well as sort of
so it covers more distant areas in the
borough and I think I just would like
some reassurance that that will be
considered in the review going forwards
and it wouldn't just be the fact that it
doesn't meet the criteria therefore a
decision is going to be made based on
that
um absolutely and I think I suppose
there's several things and the purpose
of this report was just to look at needs
um and we did look at Travel distances
so I
I think the two context points I would
put is that
um when we looked at the I absolutely
take your point because altering in
general altering a minor injuries unit
only dealt with injuries it did mean
that it was dealing with a very specific
set of people and the people who were
attending there from the data we have
tended to be very local and from the
more affluent parts of our population
and the data the data since it's been
shut has shown that those people have
gone to wythenshaw hospital which also
actually also caters for our more
affluent some of the more affluent parts
of our population for people in
Partington I think the more obvious
places that they would go would be
Trafford General
um because that can cater for that has
both parts and I think while you've got
traffic General there
the people in Partington are probably
more likely to use that and certainly in
the past we're more likely to use that
than um to travel to alteringham uh the
traffic links between alteringham and
Partington aren't particularly good
whereas there is a better link
um although you know there are issues
around transport generally from
Partington the the one good link is
actually up to the hospital
um the as well in the north of the
borough obviously access to Manchester
Royal infirmary and the Manchester
Foundation trust is extremely good
um people in the north of the borough
typically would attend those that that
site so
um all I can see from the data I have
and from the travel patterns and so on
is is what we have I can't obviously
there isn't a minor illness unit at
ultringham minor injuries unit so I
we're in the Realms of speculation but
just looking at where people travel more
generally I am relatively confident that
there are Partington population are
mainly served by Trafford General and
have always been
sorry just just to answer that as well
just to be clear
um obviously I think it's really quite
easy isn't it to jump to the Assumption
assumptions or get to the conclusion bit
where we think we can make
recommendations so just to give some um
some Assurance on that level we are just
literally at the needs assessment side
so at the stage where we know exactly
where we currently are as Trafford as
Gareth said in the beginning in the
introduction we are working towards
um looking at all the data and the
analysis to come forward and back to
scrutiny obviously with recommendations
about how we see the best landscape
moving for Trafford based on the
information that's contained with the
needs assessment but we also need to be
really clear that we the financial
position for Trafford won't change as in
the Urgent Care envelope that we've got
to pay for services remains and we don't
anticipate that going bigger or smaller
anytime soon so the envelope is the
envelope so we have to work with what
the current um financial means that we
have available to us but we will get to
the the next stages in regards to the
development of the review thank you
okay councilor Hartley
thank you chair I've um I've got three
issues that I'd like to ask about MMA so
um the first one is is is my confusion
about the travel times information so
um so I know one of the key findings is
um Trafford is the second best rate of
access to hospitals in GM based on
public transport or walking
um H 8.4 within 30 minutes
um
in in the report there are some maps and
I I got confused I don't know if the
maps have been mixed up possibly so uh
or maybe I'm just not understanding it
um so they are at uh page
oh hang on sorry
page numbering is is different on the
page 49 and 50 I think it is yeah
um
and on page 49 there's the commentary at
7.6 and 7.7 which uh seems to say 2019
2020 when altering a minor interest unit
was open at that point nearly 90 of our
residents could access a hospital site
by public transport within 30 minutes
and then Mach 5 shows a situation in
2122 when management unit was suspended
um and at that point
trafford's position seems to fall to
from second to sixth in GM but then the
maps four and five don't don't seem to
show that and that doesn't tell it with
the finding so I just wondered so that
figure of nearly 90 can access
um
hospital care within 30 minutes is that
is that based on altering a minor
injuries unit being open or is that
basically being closed because the
difference is significant between 45 and
90 obviously so so the if mind altering
a minor injuries unit is open then it's
we're at the 90 figure
if it's closed we're at the lower figure
however the lower figure the higher
figure fails to take into account that
actually you could only use altering a
minor injuries unit if you had an injury
and therefore that 90 is an inflated
figure because all the people who had
minor illnesses already had to travel
somewhere else so we're working on the
maps and the data we have but it is a
bit confusing that 90 the 90 90 figure
is an inflation of what was actually
there the other issue is and this is why
I was so Keen to do and transport for
greater Manchester I have to say have
been fabulous in supporting us with
these Maps
um I was very interested in the impact
of the transport related social
exclusion because what you don't want to
do is take away something that people
who have trouble getting anywhere else
then have nowhere to go and when we
looked at the when we asked um transport
for greater Manchester to to give us the
data on the transport related social
exclusion we found that the only area of
traffic with significant level of
Transport related social exclusion was
in um it was Partington a couple of very
small areas elsewhere and that's mainly
that's because of a very much High our
car ownership across Trafford is very
high with the exception of Partington
so so that this is I mean you know
public health is an Arts as well as the
science and my judgment was what I was
seeing was that actually most of the
population in Trafford is well served
under either option at the moment I'm
not wanting to prejudge what the end of
any consultation is
um I'm just
describing the data that I see and and
share and I think we were and we were
very very pleased to have Heather from
healthwatch within our um Urgent Care
needs assessment group
um and um you know I'm a public health
person I'm really happy to be challenged
on any of the data that we put forward
um I think that's that's you know we've
included a lot in order to have that
healthy debate and to ensure that you
can see what we've done you can see our
workings and you can ask us about them
as indeed you are doing so
um that's good thank you um sorry and I
should have said the report I think is
really interesting so
um it's not too long I think it gives us
a lot of really really useful
information about you know the current
state of urgent care
um
so the my second question was um
so I think Kathy you touched on this
when you mentioned there were several
different routes into urgent care and uh
different front doors
um and they're they're in the annex uh
in in the table although
I think yeah I think I don't think some
of them are
um they're really accessible by patients
I think patients would get referred into
them and uh
um I think maybe unlike councilor Lloyd
I wouldn't be sure actually where to go
sometimes and I can remember
conversations when my children were
younger with my wife about what we do we
film on one more
um and and
well Trafford General I mean it's a
while since I've been there but I think
that's maybe the confusion is acute
there because you have the two providers
as you mentioned James there's also a GP
out of our service there and so whenever
I've been I always get told I'm in the
wrong place
um which I actually I don't I don't
think is broken I don't think the
patient's in the wrong place I think the
system isn't isn't set up right um but
um I mean that's sort of anecdotal but
there is there is evidence in the report
that you that you've mentioned I know
from healthwatch and you mentioned this
James around
um you know people not knowing what
services are there at Trafford General
and the other example is um somebody
saying they've got to the Urgent
Treatment Center in the middle of the
night and it's not open
but I do understand the confusion just
just looking at that table and all the
different routes into urgent care I can
I can understand it and
you know the urgent treatment center at
Trafford is open eight to eight but
they're on at MRI and it Windsor was
eight till ten so you've got the same
service different hours so
um so I suppose the question is we've
got all those
um different routes in different front
doors and and
uh why why have we got to that point is
it to do with the pressure on the system
and triaging patients more effectively
um so I guess I'm asking is there any
scope to simplify that and then that
might make
um sort of educating people to use the
right service easier thank you yeah
you're absolutely right I think
we are working together as a system and
actually very not coincidentally because
it's all been engineered to get to this
place but we are having
um an Urgent Care workshop on Friday I
know that the term Workshop might not be
the right term but we are getting
together as system Partners so that's
ourselves mft
um the operational teams who deliver
urgent care services and also some of
our GM colleagues as well
um to look up at the Urgent Care
landscape how that works across managers
to run Trafford to
um seamlessly streamline one what Urgent
Care looks and feels like and also the
terminology in which we use because I
think that's particularly confusing
timing wise and then as a system across
Manchester and Trafford we can make it
really clear where you go to reach
services and what you go to them for so
it's it's going to be an ever-evolving
Beast because National guidance changes
quite regularly as I'm sure you've seen
um but there isn't any anticipated
changes for Urgent Treatment Centers
certainly in in the coming
um few years so what we expect is as a
system we will agree what accessibility
looks like and also the communication
across Manchester and Trafford so even
if you live on the border and you might
potentially want to go to MRI or go to
Salford et cetera which number of our
patients do it's a consistent approach
and a consistent offer and consistent
timeliness of opening particularly on
the MRI sites for example it will be
system pressure why that's they've got
an extended period because their demand
might be is it is more certainly than
the Trafford General site just because
of the location Etc and but we please be
assured we are working in system
partners and part of this review will be
to come back with any changes
recommendations and so we can update you
about the landscape and how that might
be evolving and changing thank you
thank you very much and and final
question chair if if I'm a is is so I
might be jumping a gun here so if I am
then you can you can tell me to just
wait
um but picking up on what councilor
Lester said around
you know whether because the minor
injuries unit is an anomaly and you know
whether it should be an urgent treatment
center if that if that's the road that
is recommended how
easy would that be to do to put an
urgent treatment center altering him is
that an easy thing to do or is that not
an easy thing to do
foreign
we've not even looked at the the
possibilities as we said this is
literally the the outline of what need
the needs are in Trafford currently
we've not got to any of the analysis
about what the proposals might look and
feel like that will take again all
system partners coming together if to
look at what the scalability of that
would be financially with kind of we've
not even touched on the solutions yet
but obviously we'll bring those back
thank you
thank you chair
um thanks Kathy and Eleanor and the rest
of you for the for the report I think
it's you've done a really really good
job in a very short period of time to
have um got all that data together for
us and I think that I think what we've
got to be clear about it's a review of
our urgent care right across Trafford
it's not about a specific site it's
about everything that um our residents
um access and I think it we need to be
um you know really looking at um
how we make sure that our residents
understand where to go I think that that
is the big big issue for us and I think
you know as Ward councilors you know we
we when we're out and about we should be
reminding people that you know go to the
chemist first or go to the Opticians
because I gave an example at a meeting
yesterday my daughter has been suffering
with an eye bleed and my mum died of a
subarachnoid hemorrhage and obviously we
were panicking that she was having some
sort of episode so she I'm not going
doctor she went well she couldn't get
into the doctors but she went round the
corner to the chemist and he just said
to go over to the precinct because we
live in Stratford and um they'll scan
our eye for you at
um Specsavers so she went in and they
looked at it and it was I went in with
her because I was like to hold a hand
you know could even if your child's 37
you're still you're still the mum aren't
you and so I went in with her making
sure that they weren't poking her or
doing anything cruel to her you know
like you would with an under five and
um it was it was amazing you know they
just said it the optician was able to
um say to her you know you've just got a
week at um vein in your eye and it'll be
something that you will have on many
occasions and it's not that you you know
you've got a massive brain bleed or
anything and that prevented us then
having to go and do all the stuff so I
think it's about understanding where you
need to go and I think that people think
Urgent Care means accident and emergency
and it doesn't it means to go and do all
those other routes and then if you need
accident and emergency you know you'll
be getting blue lighted somewhere so I
think that we need to be you know we
need to be
banging that drum all the time about
what is available in the community
because I think the stuff that we're
going to do around localities going
forward with this part of the integrated
care service we will be I think we will
be explaining to people that this is the
way to go and so um I'd just like to
thank you for for what you've done and I
think that the you know the way that
you're going to capture some more
information as part of the survey and
stuff where you're going to go and out
and do actually one you know
face-to-face groups of people that are
hard to reach I think that is really
really good it's not often that we do
that sort of um consultation so I think
it's really important and I just you
know we are in
um you know an age of cuts and I just
think that people need to be mindful
that the envelope that we have for
health is the envelope that we have for
health so
um you know we want to get the best we
want people to be going to the right
place so that we're not actually
charging the health you know the
hospital loads of money when you could
just nip over to the precinct to see you
if to see the optician so thanks for
everything you've done it's been
absolutely you know it's a brilliant
report and look look forward to the
outcomes in the end thank you
and and I just wanted to thank councilor
Slater very much for that because I
think a lot of this work when you look
at Urgent Care on its own that's not how
we live our lives we need to think of
this about that holistic approach and
and you know the plant and preventative
care and those roles most Urgent Care is
delivered in localities is delivered as
councilor Slaters has said and we've all
been talking about the role of Pharmacy
the role of GPS but actually making sure
that we've got our plans and
preventative Services based on our
neighborhood locality model so that
people can walk to the services that
they need to use that they're embedded
in that local community respect
respectful of and um appropriate to
local variations in need that's where
we're going to really start seeing that
maximization of our overall health
starting as as Kathy has said with the
self-care and then building that up and
Urgent Care should be the thing that you
really don't want to be using and you
you were it's the stop Gap it's got to
be there of course it's got to be there
and it's got to be a high quality but
really data today most of us it's much
more about our self-care the
conversations we were having about
supporting Behavior change and so on in
Partington and then building up that
preventative offer the plan care offer
and of course that urgent care and
emergency care for when we need it but
hopefully we'll do everything else right
and we won't need it as much
councilor Taylor I'm not really going to
say too much because I think that the
point that I was going to raise as being
Illustrated perfectly with your example
Jane and your your answers really that
Urgent Care starts with self-care and
what's available in the community and I
think that was a brilliant example so
can I just thank you very much for your
report it's really extensive and
excellent and I don't know how you've
pulled it together in such a short
period of time but I think it will lay
the foundation won't it for you know
making recommendations for for how we
proceed really and it's it's reassuring
to know that what is in existence
already
um does serve the population well and
um and I think it is probably those
other things that are away from the
traditional perception of
um urgent care that probably needs to be
capitalized on more but yeah your your
point illustrates what I wanted to ask
perfectly so thank you very much
well thank you um very comprehensive
report good
sorry I didn't
you go ahead
so um couch Brophy here I don't have a
lot to say because most of my questions
have already been answered
um by the report itself and I Echo the
comments that others have made about
it's a truly excellent report compared
to we get a lot of reports here at
Health scrutiny and sometimes they are
quite hard to understand and it's quite
hard to work out what what the report's
about and this one it's really really
clear so I think the level of Engagement
you've got with the councilors on this
is excellent just because it's such an
easy report to read and it's all
color-coded and some of the questions I
was going to ask have already been asked
so I'm just gonna focus on one
particular point that I don't think has
been covered by anybody
so I was looking at page 45 which is all
the providers in Trafford
um and where people go to and it's got
dates I think this is really significant
this chart because it kind of shows you
what's happened so like when the Ultram
minor induced unit closed you can it it
looks almost like well they've all gone
to wither I think that was already said
um and there's no increase at um Oxford
Road from from what we can see and I was
also looking at this thing here this
absolutely intrigues me this where all
the dots are because I think one of the
missing pieces of data on this perhaps
but you'll know is it gives you like um
The Journey times or particular points
on the map
and it's for a hospital so I think that
might be a bit misleading because it the
hospital gives you different levels of
care doesn't it there's it could be just
like altering of its minor injuries or
it could be the urgent care or it could
be the full a e
so I think I'd like to see if anything
um what that looks like for the acute
access as well because I think it would
change wouldn't it those colors would
change if you didn't have
altering a minor injuries unit that all
those red bits around
the south of traffic that they would all
change color wouldn't they and that's
the thing maybe we do want to look at is
what would happen if we didn't have
altering minor energy unit there so
that's that's in the map Above So map
four so the map above shows what it
would be like if you didn't
tell me what Peter is so that's on page
49 49 and then page 50 shows what
happens if altering them is minor
injuries unit is there which
deliberately did it yeah
both comparisons with and without that
is a bit I think that was just I was
looking at this one but my my eyesight
isn't quite good enough to have worked
that one out without the zoning in so
that's really helpful to know
yes thank you for that I said that the
report because everything we might
possibly want to ask I think the only
other point may be echoing some of the
other Cancer's points is it gives you
all the picture of where we are now but
I think the interesting part is like
what happens next and
um
I think that alteringham minor injuries
unit it depends what what your plans are
for it because as one of the other
councilors said
if there is scope to make that into a
more um extensive service maybe that
makes those um
all the different things come together I
don't know it but it's just a thought if
it's not viable The Way It Is What would
need to change to make it a more useful
viable part of the community or other
other thoughts around what could happen
next we can't make comment at this stage
obviously but that'll all be part of the
um other suggestions and feedback of the
review and the needs assessment and
we'll move forward from there but
obviously we'll come back with any and
I'm sure we'll engage though we will
engage as we have done in regards to the
development of this as well thank you
um okay well thank you very much lots of
glowing reports for the report there so
um and a lot of good questions from from
the committee so thank you everybody for
that and uh
that's it I just want and I just want to
be really clear that this review is not
a review of all Stringer minor injuries
unit what comes after this review if
there is a need for a review of that
unit that will take place so I don't
want us to take our eye off the ball on
this I think we need to be really
focused about what urgent care really is
and it isn't just about altering a minor
injury so thank you chair
okay and yes thank you for um adding
your clarifications to that
um
and
um
I I agree with that but I would just
um add to it that there is still um an
expectation out uh there in the
community particularly in the The Wider
Ultram community that uh that they will
hear something before long about about
that uh facility let's call it that
without pinpointing it too much more
than that but
um what I was saying was
um thank you very much for the report
and for the um the answers you give to
you gave to a lot of good questions from
the committee and um
will await events
okay
so item eight is the ICS update
wow I'll put that on so you can hear me
so so just to say I'm down on the
agendas Director of Finance so that was
a form alive I'm now currently the
deputy Place lead for Health and Care
integration
Branch FGM traffic locality so just for
future reference Stephanie thank you so
the last time I came it seems only like
five minutes ago when we were talking
about this I gave a verbal update and
I've given several before so there was
clear feedback that you wanted a written
report and so what we've shared this
time is the report that went to the
Trafford locality partnership board
yesterday of the key things and what we
do each month there at the locality
board is share the key themes
currently in the development of the
integrated care system and what's
relevant for the Trafford locality board
and its Partners so what we've done is
share that
I won't go through the whole of the
report but I'll just take it as read and
conscious of time I'll just pull a few
of the headlines out if that's okay
chair so it's the last time I came I
talked about the work we were doing to
understand what we described as the
operating model and what we mean by that
is who does what where basically so
whether things are done at your GM level
or down in the localities of which there
are 10 and so so that work is still
ongoing and I did talk last time about a
slight pause to that with the
implementation of a mutually agreeable
resignation scheme which is part of the
plan to reduce the head count across
nhfgm but do that on a voluntary basis
without the need hopefully for more more
stringent measures moving forward so
that work to agree the structures has
been paused and we won't finish that
transformation program as an NHS gym
until the end of June now saying that it
was still making progress and we do
understand a lot more now about what is
required of the locality so so I think
although it's negative in some ways that
it's being important I think the work we
do and the understanding we have now I
think is far greater than it was prior
to Christmas when I last came
just in terms of that one of the key
things that's changed is that we've now
received our draft budgets both in terms
of the corporate budget you know for the
staff in the locality team and also the
service level budget you know so what
will be delegated down to the locality
board so so I've included some of the
details of both of those I was just
going to pick on the latter
for a second if that's okay because I
talked about the corporate budget last
time I think when I came
so in terms of what will be delegated to
the locality
some of the things that are any of what
we expected basically you know is going
to be delegated to us so this budget
you'll see is far smaller than the
budget of the ccg and that's because a
lot of the functions and the bigger
contracts will be held at the GM level
and some of that it will be done once I
think I've described that previously but
what's delegated down formally
or will be from the 1st of April to the
10 localities are the things which
really have the impact on what we've
been talking about this evening already
so things like the primary care budget
Primary Care prescribing budgets some
elements of urgent care
and things like that you know delegated
down
um to the locality so so one of the key
points I wanted to make is
and there's a great debate at the moment
you know across GM
by what's meant by the word The Joint
stewardship is a phrase that's been used
quite often at the moment so what we
mean by that in my understanding of that
is even if things are formally delegated
down to the locality board it's still
very relevant to the conversations we
have at locality board and indeed here
as well so so the paragraphs 15 and 16
I've included a direct lift from the
target operating model so so things you
know
sorry it describes things still being
brought to the table even if the
contract is held at a GM level and the
budget isn't formally delegated down
things like urgent care and community
services are really good examples of
those things so I might not have the
budget and the control of the budget
from the first of April but all that
information will still flow through the
locality board and our partnership
discussions that we have them down and
Nathan's team have with local a
community in the queue a provider
colleague so I think that's a really
important point
I think in different people have
different interpretations of what that
means but I think that we've had some
really positive discussions through the
locality board and getting to that you
know Collective view of what that means
so I don't think even though some of the
budgets aren't delegated formally I
still think that we'll have a skin in
the game and those you know those key
services so so I am feeling more
positive about that moving forward and
then just briefly in terms of governance
and I've spoken about this in some
detail previously is that the locality
board yesterday we made two decisions
and one was to delay what we were
planning around the time scales I think
that I described last time so so all
localities have to confirm by the turn
of the financial year what the formal
legal governance structure will be so
will we be a formal subcommittee or a
committee of the ICB or will we be
something else so we we're working with
Partners having really good
conversations and you um and we are
moving that back by four weeks so Our
intention is to take our preferred model
around that and that's emerging through
those partner discussions to the
February locality board and then we'll
take all the paperwork and there's quite
a lot of paperwork through the ICB
formal board meeting in March I think
initially the there was quite a bit of
pressure to move quite quickly but now
there are five localities who will be
following suit and doing that in Mars so
so I think we're in good company and it
makes perfect sense so so that exact
Clarity of what the locality board will
look like is still being worked through
but again
Department discussion is really positive
and I think we're all pretty much on the
same page in terms of what we will be in
order to receive those delegations down
that I described a bit earlier
the second thing we agreed yesterday
very quickly was it in the interim
period while we're agreeing the
governance that the new leader of the
council the Council of Russia will be
the co-chair you know like Andrew was
before that so so that's positive too
um and you know
as part of the work we're doing around
the government then that will involve a
new set of terms of reference and that
will involve the model around sharing so
so I can't say much more on that but
the council Ross will be the interim
co-chair
so I'll pause there take any questions
and also some feedback on the report
what we've done is just shared the
report that went to locality board we
can do more or less if that's required
and so so take some feedback on the
report with wheelchair if that's okay
thank you
Mr Gilbert yeah
hi um so
it's more an observation I'm not a
healthcare professional so feel free to
put me back in my box on this one I
guess it just is my second year sitting
on health scrutiny and it seems to have
taken a really long time to get where we
are now and
um and there's I'm seeing the governance
and the budgets and you know obviously
that's incredibly important what as what
seems to be quite far away is the impact
that this has had the benefits this has
on on patience and our you know our
residents in Trafford and you know are
we are we kind of the same as everybody
else across the country or have other
people who have formed other
organizations that have formed ics's uh
are they further ahead of us
um because I'm kind of looking to see
now the benefits and and maybe some
negative impacts of the of this and it
just seems to be taking a rather long
time so that's not a personal criticism
it's just an observation from from the
outside I would be kind of hoping to
hear more about patients by now
um and then uh probably my
um
my second point on that really is just
what um what do we think the
um the the risks are with the Mars
program that you're going to offer and
um kind of loss of talent yeah thanks
it's kind of you sort of wrap my mind a
bit about where you were coming from
because I'm struggling a bit with the
report itself because
I'm I'm finally I don't actually
understand I mean I do work in the
health sector and I've been a member of
this committee for quite a long time and
usually you can kind of understand the
wider context of report what it means
the point of the previous counselor what
does it mean for patients and I I don't
really get this report at all I don't
know what it's trying to say it might be
but the bit that really stands out for
me is
it says um the Secretary of State for
Health and Social care is written to all
ICB chairs to publish an organogram
um and then this asks to support the
Health and Care department store commit
and all that so how the money is spent
so I mean we see on the news every day
about the struggles in the hospitals we
saw from the previous report about
um the pressures on urgent and acute
care and we could see within Shore
Hospital right up there with the number
of patients going in there now my
assumption is because you know we hear
about it all the time on the news that
if we could fix the social care side of
things then that would mean everything
would work better and people's
experience of the Whole Health System
would work so much better if we fixed
the social care side so I'm wondering is
is that where we're heading for because
at the moment I can't see how this is
heading in that direction or maybe I'm
just not seen
where it's began where where you're up
to and what's happening next because
like the previous counselor I can't I
wasn't on the committee for last year
but I still can't really get a grasp of
what the report's about please explain a
bit more
thank you for both those comments and
I'll
try and answer them together but I'll
start with the at this counselor's
question first so
I think it does feel as if we've been
talking about governance and
transforming the system for a long time
and we have been I mean this has been a
long time in the making I think it was
partly due to a number of factors there
was a delay if you recall in the passing
of the health and care bill so we were
talking about for a long time but then
couldn't act then there was a delay in
the appointment of ICB executive team so
all of those things conspired against us
a little bit I think in terms of the
question are we behind I don't think we
are behind at most
yep
most icbs have done things slightly
differently so I know I have colleagues
in other
mycbs across the north west and things
have been done differently
but I don't think we're behind too much
in terms of the development of the
system I think just in terms of you know
what this means the impact on patients
that we continue to monitor the
performance and the quality impact of
what we do as a Health and Social care
system you know so that continues
through through existing governance and
new governance and we're having
conversations about how we can improve
that so those conversations haven't
stopped just because we're transforming
and in some ways we've kept some things
in double runs some committees just to
make sure we keep an eye on that but
that's not to say
performance has dips I mean there's no
doubt you know we looked at some some
key metrics of the locality board
yesterday and there were you know some
really sort of worrying performance
against some key metrics so and we can
bring stuff back and talk about that as
much as we need I think the issue we've
got here I'm facing that since I've been
coming and I've been asked I thought the
exam question was to explain the
development of the new system and
transformation of the new system not the
business as usual of the impact on
patients and quality now we've we're
moving now away from this and I would
love to I promise you I would love to
move away from these discussions around
governance and move to the so what the
impact that future reports can include
that because because there's a rich
set of intelligence around around the
impact on quality and performance
measures and as I said it doesn't make
great reading at the moment in terms of
performance and financial performance
couples as well so so I think that's why
perhaps we're a bit stuck
in governance and the system that we're
trying to develop and I'm happy to move
away from that for future reports to to
the scrutiny committee or do a balance
of two things really just a quick
follow-up on that because I think um
we're
part committee here with some Ward
councilors representing residents so
where we're coming from is the sort of
more our residence experience for the
Health and Social Care Systems so whilst
the governance is important in terms of
our scrutiny what we will probably find
more useful is the second part you were
talking about there the impact on
patients and what it means for where
we're heading in terms of the pressures
on the hospital system and how to
develop social care things like the
staffing issues might be interesting to
know but just the whole picture how it
impacts on our residents and patients I
think we do need perhaps I could ask
through the chair is that something
that's
um going to come to a future committee
that something a bit more explaining
what where we're heading what direction
this is going in overall in terms of
patients and residence
ready to talk about the medicine
um
[Music]
thank you chair
um and I think gareth's point about the
the reports on the updates have been
coming for about probably about a year
haven't they so we're finding it long
it's taking longer than we would like
and we'd share your um View and but
there are some really good examples and
I think you know the fact that Gareth
and I sit together we work together
every day we've got we've got um we've
created a fund that we've put monies
together this year to to provide
discharge to assess beds it's a much
higher level than we would have been
able to do without working and funding
that in a collaborative way and the
outcomes are hundreds of people have
gone home to be with their families when
they would have spent a lot longer in
hospital fixing social care really good
really clear dead simple ex example for
you and we can bring a lot of of that
stuff in I think it would be good for
you to see some of the the benefits of
the working together which is what this
was about however it has it's a national
change it has taken a long time there's
a lot of people involved in gareth's
team that have gone through two years of
trauma really with the changes and it's
a credit to them because they've kept
resilient and strong and very focused on
our locality plan that Tom supports us
with implementing and we've seen some
great outcomes be lovely to share them
with you so I I would really want to do
that I think tonight you've seen
examples of joint working around a
substance misuse support and the alcohol
support and the Urgent Care review is a
really good example public health and
Gareth teams for the HS Trafford sitting
together working through what do we need
why do we need it where do we need it
and then and then coming and sharing
that and then going out to talk to the
public about that the sort of what do
they understand by or so I think there's
some great examples we probably need to
move this phase perhaps into the maybe
the last report on governance updates
and and start to move into the sort of
what are the programs of work that you
would want to see and I know we've got
um we have a scrutiny in March I think
is the last one before elections isn't
it so maybe if we could get a couple of
examples for you there you will see some
of the benefits they're asked lots of
processes to work through because that
enables you to get further in you in
your planning
yeah yeah I was just going to say the
timing works quite well actually so so
we're hoping to agree you know our
governance in February through the
locality board and so we could bring a
final and I'll make it very a bridge
version of where we got to but then
concentrate on some of the other good
work that we're doing in terms of that
joint working and the impact on the
residents I think yeah thank you Council
Lloyd
um
well I think uh councilor Gilbert was
asking uh some of what I wanted to ask
um and just to say yeah it does seem a
long process and I've been through lots
of
um
reorganizations this seems to have been
the longest ever
and it's it's stupid because it does
actually I know you're saying you're
trying to get it uh just patient out in
looking at Patients outcomes and things
but that's not the sense that's coming
across here and councilor Gilbert did
ask a question about the risks of the
Mars and also my question relates to the
allocation of money to Trafford now I
know you say that some centrally health
so therefore we only have an allocation
but you've got the um the Masters to
settle
um we've got our allocation and is it
in line with what we've received before
in Trafford or is it less
or has it got an uplift even because
given the
um
um the cost of living crisis Etc are all
the pressures that are coming on for
expensive uh things like heating
lighting and everything else
and we should have had an uplift have we
had an uplift in the money that we've
received
thank you so it's Thursday
um an apologies I forgot with all the
excitement I forgot the Mark I forgot
the Mars question and so so the impact
across GM is unknown yeah I you know
understand it's probably less than they
thought or hoped in terms of the numbers
for the Trafford locality team I can't
say too much because we we haven't
concluded the process but I'm aware of
two applications that are coming through
and we will manage that within within
our resources
um and any payments any Severance
payments are picked up by GM not through
the locality budget so that I think you
mentioned that too
in terms of the overall budget so so the
budget we've got is much smaller because
it doesn't cover all of the previous
functions but Pro rata it's based on
what we spent previously plus an uplift
based on National planning guidance for
this year
I haven't I haven't got that figure
sorry in my head for because it's based
on last year I can find out and and
share could you find out please before
the next meeting so that and we know
what the uplift is and what the
pressures are in relation to that
because that's it does matter
um in in terms of resources as to what
we can provide and
um I know in previous reincarnations
some Services were hit by a lack of
resources absolutely and I think it's if
you've got any
that are standing out I think we should
know
[Music]
and I'm aware that obviously that and
the trade unions have been heavily
involved with members who are going
through that process and what we have
with the ICB which we didn't have with
the ccg uh the GMC CG is that we
actually have a union member on the
board now which I think is a big which
is a vast Improvement I think for us
anyway so
um I just wanted to say to you that the
unions have been heavily involved in
that and of people looking at negotiated
exits if that's what they want
foreign
foreign
so um
we've just got the uh the work program
to
conclude
um
Stephanie do you want to
um
just
comment on the work program
yes I think we have
um Tom was uh quite rightly drawing our
attention there particularly the second
item uh the national legislation was
being delayed to 2025.
and I think you possibly have some
information around that
um hi everyone Tom Maloney speaking very
late in the meeting to introduce myself
program director across health and care
for the Council on NHS gym Trafford
um so in in conversations with Diane we
said um and with original originally
scheduled this at the beginning of the
year when we created the forward plan
obviously due to the delays um so that
there's oscillation coming through uh we
think it works not worth the update now
given that significant DeLay So a
proposal really to postpone that Heisman
bring that back at um a more suitable
date into the future and obviously
consider that as part of 2324's work
program
um and I think also there was some
feedback from colleagues particularly in
gareth's team my team
um around the elective update as well
which is on their chair and so
a number of issues with regards to
access to data and that data being
available at the middle of March from
mft from it's just a foundation trust to
give us the full picture and I think
that was one of the points of feedback
from the last group to the meeting is
that we need you know we need the data
and it's entirety to be able to have an
informed conversation and I'm led to
believe that that data isn't going to be
available till the middle of March so
obviously that doesn't align with the
first of March which I think is the next
uh scheduled meeting of this committee
so
um a again a suggestion to defer that to
the next meeting the new Municipal year
um I have inquired as to whether or not
we could bring back a sort of interim
Report with what data we do have and I'm
waiting to hear some feedback on that
and I should have an answer by the end
of this week but my initial the initial
response is that there won't be a great
deal so it's the benefits to the
committee of spending time on something
that we probably need to park and maybe
do in more detail in full as a future
meeting
okay
um
I'm not suggesting we delay the um
charging changes um unnecessarily but
the delay nationally is until
2025. so I think you've got time to look
at it at her for the date
and hopefully it won't get lost which
would be my biggest worry that
nationally it will disappear
okay well it's just leaving us looking
very
just uh with looking like we would have
very light agenda for the next meeting
is the
others of that new computer system at
mft because I think that if if that's
the reason think members need to
understand that the
um if it is just explain it yeah an
adult profess to know that the ins and
outs of the new system so the hive
system within MFC which has um been
implemented over the past number of
months that is a contribution factor to
it so it hence why you know with the new
it system that's gone live
um that that doesn't we aren't able to
draw through that data yet but we are
intending on to getting that level of
data by the middle of March so that is
the main contributing factor um is my
understanding the intricacies of that
um not not don't profess to know I'm
afraid
okay
um
[Music]
the only thing that I've got to sort of
add to the debate is we've had a very
good suggestion from councilor Gilbert
about the
um a matter for for us to look into
which is um
antenatal classes
um and I don't know
if the scope for something to be
prepared for the for the next meeting as
purely because we've got such a light
agenda
so I'm antenatal or maternity services
are offered by mft so we'll need to just
check back and check availability Etc
but we can look into that for you
okay well that will Fast Track it from
your point of view about it so uh
hopefully there'll be something there
councilor Brophy
um does the time scales allow for the
suggestion we had for a more from Dan
Eaton and about the Integrated Health
and Social care does it allow for
example like some examples we looked at
to add to the report we have today so we
can see the benefits does that is that
something that could be looked at for
March
well let's turn it the other way around
either and say to that Dan
given the the a small amount of time
there is would you just do what you can
for a gender item for for March
um it would be a pleasure because it
will be my last scrutiny with you as
well before I retire so it'd be nice to
think something something could really
have good news I would suggest that a
focus on the use of discharge to assess
facilities as a way to support discharge
activity which has really helped us and
the improvements in our home care
availability perhaps as two items and we
have information we could bring in for
you on that
okay
I think that
sorts that item out relatively
satisfactorily and um
we'll we'll just check with the task and
finish groups if there's any updates or
whatnot they can report on the same
agenda
um just to update the reports
um
so
um
have no urgent business
so that concludes the meeting so could I
thank everybody for once again a very
good input into what I think has been a
um a very interesting meeting very
thought-provoking indeed so uh thank you
very much everybody
okay
[Music]